hello and welcome this video playing a
little bit with black let's see we and
this is one of the lines where I
absolutely no I I know that I don't know
it which is probably better than not
knowing it but not knowing that you
don't know it did that make any sense
probably not
and okay so what now I act that is on
the board more than once and I was
always in trouble and I always thought I
should really check this should really
look at this and then it kept gets
played against me again and I'm in
trouble
even that feels like a div like I had
this on the board a million times and
lost a million times
yeah then they play whatever a for and
they're from trouble or something
now of course my pawn structure may it
shakes it takes you play screen b3 and
I'm
[Laughter]
I don't want to be lost after 17 moves
why am i lost
after 17 Moors
oh man
not sure what I should give here which
pawn
this this this thing there are things we
know things we don't know things that we
know that we don't know there is
something there somebody who said this
was that Donald Rumsfeld or somebody
that some some I think it was totally
rough of all people the former Secretary
of Defense and the George W Bush
probably someone can clarify that but I
think it was Rumsfeld when asked about
the war on terror or something and he
was really bad [ __ ] crazy him anyway
let's not go there
c4 is also a strange move why do I give
me that why why did he give me that I
get a I get some porn because I'm some
passim instead of weaknesses that's
weird okay not sure about b3 but I mean
I'm happy that I'm alive there was not
something that was given some moves ago
I can suggest take and play Quintus is
seven he will play Queen age three a
queen age three though that's something
that I should be be ready for it's tough
to be ready for that but you know one
thing I have the same it's not such a
big issue if I'm giving up the exchange
in this position if I get denied to
deform this is not such a big problem
okay he cannot take c5 Queen c6 I'm
trapping this so he will take probably
on the aid
I mean this is not not at all clear I
mean the night is monstrous and he
always has to check this beep on I'm not
even certain that this is worse for me
at least in a blitz game it's not okay
he wants to infiltrate one if five okay
I'm just stopping this playing it a bit
prophylactically I mean his looks are
just stupid stupid pieces him rookie one
rookie three has one way to activate a
rook F was stopped for the moment
thinking about g5 had some some moment
it's very difficult very difficult for
my chair this this thing wait just a
moment I'm going to win the Queen first
yeah that's all it's obviously
frustrated because the way the game went
but the the position exchange down is ok
it's really ok for me let's let's have a
look at was it well I mean I played
terrible terrible chess but so this this
is just already bad yeah it's already a
bad position
I keep miss playing this it's the line
that I have to look at really really
really urgently it costs and I get bad
positions every time and I even feel
that then I had this exactly this ok
Queen b6 and I mean I think this is all
fine what you did is fine it is just a
c4 it's just bad
it's just a bad move that Wow the engine
is immediately giving me an advantage
after it after in something like Bishop
b3 my position is toast it's just bad I
[Music]
got weaknesses all over a very funny
line is this one
ma'am this is disastrous yeah he played
c4 which immediately gives me a good
position and then probably I'm making a
mistake somewhere here so I mean I I
should avoid the loss of the exchange
it's not I'm not in trouble after it but
I should somehow avoided the engine
wants to give the exchange simply with
h6 now so maybe my problem is I
shouldn't even take yeah the engine
suggest look here 25 take take h6 okay
it's not exactly easy because this is
good for like him okay interesting
so the way it went I mean it was pretty
clear that I have a quite good play for
the exchange so the engine wants to play
Queen d7 it wants to play this with the
clear advantage from like funny now I
mean it's clear that white has no chance
of winning I you you you're just stuck
with those problems him the strong pawn
the night coming f4 and so on okay I
went 94 and gave the exchange that way
now the engine is on rough equality
yeah okay okay qg3 is helping but I
think I'm I think I'm quite quite fine
him he's probably just sitting him and
the computer says equal which is maybe
true all right I'm going here and I'm
just claiming that I mean white is never
moving those pawns forward and I can't
even try to to push h5h for things like
that that is probably happening but I
don't think black can can win probably
the assessment of equal seems fair for
the moment okay guys thanks a lot for
watching